sarah palin a patriot who knows this
land the rest of the country knows this
part of america as the Heartland a
straight talker
it's about day time and a leader who's
prepared to fight hope they change the
astroturf feed DC based businesses ready
for a new chapter in America what will
they do to stop causing our pain and
start feeling it again not afraid to ask
the tough questions pantsuit can crush
Patriots but she's got some strong rules
to live by
good that's been one of my mantras right
and Sarah Palin always tells it like it
is there is no free phone someone pays
someone always pays what we on offense
give them the truth and the truth State
of the Union especially showing young
people with actually going on wait what
does that my gender is oh man this one
on gender they shackle them to the good
ol boys okay where's she going with this
the man can only ride you when your back
is bent so strengthen it thin the man
can't ride you what the media will do
all throughout 2016 to all of us
telling us what we all deserve we have
to be candid and and the people deserve
the candidness because because that
leads to solutions they deserve
solutions amnesty no Sarah Palin the
candidness leads to solutions